phoenix persönlich für nichts persönlich
heute mit ex-bundeskanzler gerhard
schröder herzlich willkommen herzlichen
dank wäre gerne gekommen wie die
ständige vertretung das freut uns dass
in hannover und das in hannover genauer
wir treffen uns hier in der ständigen
vertretung kurz für unsere zuschauer die
das vielleicht nicht so kennen
das ist eine kneipe die der alten bonner
republik ein bisschen heiligte und an
viele alte fotos zeigt mit welchen
gedanken gehen sie denn hierdurch die
fotos heute ich war natürlich oft in
bonn in der damaligen provinz als junger
abgeordneter und 1980 zum ersten mal als
bundestagsabgeordneter hat und man traf
sich dort übrigens parteiübergreifend
die ersten jungen damals wirklich sehr
jungen grünen wandern und man saß rum
abends beim glas bier oder auch zwei und
fing an zu reden nach könnte sich etwas
entwickeln zwischen uns und dann kam
berlin also die bonner republik war zu
ende
die bundesregierung ringt nach berlin
und die damalige provinz wurde zur
ständigen vertretung ganz interessant
deswegen weil die deutsche botschaft in
der früheren ddr ja nicht botschaft
heißen durfte aus verfassungsrechtlichen
gründen sondern ständige vertretung
heißen musste und diese steht also die
ständige vertretung war dann die provinz
in berlin gibt es heute noch
und daneben auch in hannover ich weiß
nicht ich glaube in hamburg auch ich
weiß nicht wo überhaupt noch sonst aber
es gibt traditionelle rheinische küche
himmel und erde und es gibt kölsch
grauenhaftes bier aber gut das
anstreichen wir müssen uns von den alten
zeiten jetzt lösen so spannend dass hier
ist und zur aktuellen politischen
situation kommen die bestimmt ist durch
die diskussion natürlich um die pandemie
und die leute fragen sich ungeduldig von
tag zu tag lauter wann kriegen wir
endlich unser normales leben zurück wie
ist es ihnen damit
also ich finde es nicht so schlimm wie
sicher für menschen es ist die kinder
haben den ich in die schule können und
die dann home office machen müssen und
dann daneben auch noch kinder zu
betreuen haben also mein leben als
jemand der seine arbeitszeit selber
einrichten kann es natürlich weit
privilegierte als die andere
insofern diese form von entschleunigung
die damit verbunden ist ist so schlecht
nicht ich mache viel sport was man sonst
machen und spiele golf mache meine
üblichen übungen im gewichtheben im all
so was und fühle mich nicht unwohl dabei
mir fehlt natürlich auch zusammensein
mit freunden wenn die kneipe gehen wie
zum beispiel hier in die steppe oder wo
auch immer hin
aber ich habe den eindruck in
deutschland sind wir recht privilegiert
und das sollte man vielleicht auch mal
deutlich machen bei allen fehlern die
gemacht worden sind wir werden sie hier
nur drauf kommen aber in unserem
gesundheitssystem zu bürokratisch aber
funktionsfähig zu leben
auch innerhalb europas ist schon ein
privileg denn es funktioniert und
niemand auch der kassenpatient muss
nicht angst haben nicht optimal versorgt
zu werden ist schon großen vorteil denn
unser staat hat und das sollte man auch
mal begrüßen und im übrigen die tolle
arbeit derjenigen die in den
krankenhäusern ein altersheim wirklich
sich quälen für die menschen für diese
verantwortung übernommen haben da schon
großartig also funktioniert mehr als
nicht funktioniert im land gebe trotzdem
zurück zu den fehlern von denen sie
gerade gesprochen haben oder auch die
vermeintlichen fehler es gibt den
vorwurf die eu habe zu zögerlich
gehandelt es ein fehler gewesen
gemeinschaftlich den impfstoff zu
bestellen es ist gar von trudel europa
die rede
teilen sie diese kritik zu in teilen ja
zunächst einmal es war richtig zu sagen
wir machen das europäisch aber die
europäische bürokratie und
die führung dauert es offenbar nicht in
der lage gewesen zu kapieren
man kann nicht glücklich sein in einer
solchen situation dass der eine punkt
der andere punkt ich habe gelegentlich
den eindruck dass man auch firmen im
geschäft halten wollte d wie sanofi zb
im ergeben ist dann nicht liefern
konnten
und auch da scheint es jedenfalls so ist
mein eindruck
zur verzögerung gekommen nein die hat
nicht hätten sein müssen oder zweite
will ich klar sagen das was herr spahn
vor hatte eigentlich nämlich auch
national neben der europäischen
dimension impfstoff zu bestellen gerade
aus deutschland denn die deutschen waren
ja gut
bei der entwicklung das wäre richtig
gewesen da sind versäumnisse vorgekommen
aber wo kommen die nicht vor in einer
solchen situation in der wir waren und
immer noch sind insofern die kritik
jetzt ist wohlfeil etliche es ist okay
daran an dieser kritik anderes
übertrieben ist aber nicht jetzt sind
wir in der situation in deutschland
warten die man schon sehnsüchtig auf den
impfstoff und wenn wir nach
großbritannien schauen sehen wir dass
die briten gerade die eu verlassen haben
deutlich schneller bestellt haben dort
nicht mehr bestellt haben und in der
impfrate weit vor uns liegen das ist
misslich würde ich auch sagen das ist
ein organisatorisches versagen das vor
allen dingen bei der eu-kommission zu
sehen ist denn wenn man vergleicht die
kosten die es macht in der pandemie zeit
im wirtschaftlichen bereich verglichen
mit dem was man hätte vielleicht in den
sand gesetzt wenn man den falschen
impfstoff bestellt hätte oder zu viel
davon bestellt hätte es ja kein
vergleich insofern glaube ich dass sich
die europäische bürokratie auch die
deutliche führung die dafür
verantwortliche kommissarin nicht mit
ruhm bekleckert haben das muss man dann
auch kritisch sagen aber alles in allem
ist es ein
situation gewesen die so neu und so von
so großer dimension war dass man ein
bisschen freundlicher sein muss auch was
diese berechtigte kritik an gehen ich
will es jedenfalls bleiben ein weiterer
punkt in der debatte ist im moment aber
es privilegien für geimpfte geben soll
wie zum beispiel konzertbesuche
restaurantbesuche der ethikrat
beschäftigt sich mit der frage wie sehen
sie das
schauen sie ich glaube er nicht es gibt
juristische gründe dafür sagt wenn man
niemanden mehr anstecken kann dürfen
grundrechts einschränkungen ein wenig
sein
das kann ich nachvollziehen ich habe das
ja mal studiert auf der anderen seite
geht es aber auch um gleichheit und
niemand weiß ganz genau ob jemand der
geimpft ist möglicherweise erst zum
ersten mal ob denn nicht wirklich auch
noch andere anstecken kann
und im übrigen jetzt ja auch darum wer
kriegt denn überhaupt impfstoff können
diejenigen die die möglichkeit haben
sich privilegierte chancen zu
verschaffen und dann besser dastehen was
restaurantbesuche usw angeht ist das in
ordnung oder macht es nicht doch sinn in
einer solchen situation zu sagen bevor
wir die pandemie nicht überwunden haben
bevor wir nicht das was man
herdenimmunität nennt erreicht haben
sollte es mich einzelne privilegierte
gebe nirgendwo bürger alle zusammen und
finde ich jedenfalls ganz gut wenn der
ethikrat sagte ok es macht diffizile
juristische gründe geben zu
unterscheiden
aber alles in allem sollten wir
zusammenbleiben als gesellschaft als
menschen in dieser gesellschaft
die bundesrepublik deutschland hat sich
kassen aufgemacht ihr ehemaliger oder
ihren genossen oder auf der wolf hat
gesagt wir haben genügend geld trotzdem
fragt man sich natürlich angesichts
dieser milliarden vermuten wo das geld
jemals wieder herkommen soll
nach 20 30
schröder ja sicher aber es kann
letztlich und da hat
olaf scholz recht nur aus wachstum
kommen stellen wir uns mal moment vor
werden nichts gemacht dann wären
wirtschaftliche strukturen richtig zu
grunde gegangen die mit geld aufrecht zu
erhalten damit sie auch in der nächsten
generation noch zur verfügung steht ist
doch vernünftig und das abtragen von
schulden muss dann über die zeit
geschehen muss über die zeit geschehen
und ist umso leichter je stärker die
strukturen erhalten bleiben die wir
brauchen um auch perspektiven für die
nächste generation zu schaffen
insofern das was die gegenwärtige
bundesregierung gemacht hat und machen
konnten wir wollen auch weil wir eine
volkswirtschaft sind die stark genug ist
im vergleich auch zu anderen
europäischen staaten war richtig kann im
einzelnen der eine oder andere fehler
vorgekommen sein aber die generelle
linie stimmte und das sage ich mit
respekt vor der gegenwärtigen
bundesregierung und zwar vor beiden von
der kanzlerin ebenso wie vor dem
finanzminister der ja in erheblichen
anteil an diesem wer das genannte wumms
hatte der mann notwendig der bams die
frage stellt sich allerdings wie es
weiter geht und es gibt eine debatte um
die schuldenbremse auf die weiter
gelockert werden kann ob man zur
staatshaushalt haushalterischen
disziplin zurückkehrt wie beurteilen sie
das ich habe noch nie sehr viel davon
gehalten weil sie doch politisches
handeln sehr sehr stark bürokratisch
einschränkt insofern finde ich die
gegenwärtige debatte darum dass man in
krisenzeiten handlungsfähig bleibt
und bleiben muss total richtig und finde
sogar das was der kanzleramtsminister
herr braun dazu gesagt hat dass
sozusagen die aufrechterhaltung von
ökonomischen strukturen wichtiger ist
als das festhalten an der schuldenbremse
kann ich unterschreiben hatte ich auch
nicht gedacht dass ich ihn jemals loben
würde gäbe nochmal zurück auf europa wir
waren gerade eben schon in sachen
impfstoff misere dort sie beklagen der
westen liege im koma in ihrem neuesten
buch und fordern einen sehr sehr
bewusste souverän ist europa mit einer
eigenen europäischen armee und die
auflösung der nato das dürfte die
amerikaner nicht wirklich amüsieren und
wir fordern nicht die auflösung der nato
um das klar zu machen sondern ihre
veränderung also das schaffen einer
stärkeren europäischen komponente warum
wir haben doch die situation dass wir
auf der einen seite amerika haben als
starke supermacht dieser sorgt bleiben
wir auf der anderen seite ein erstarken
des asien unter der führung von china
die größte volkswirtschaft demnächst der
welt mit all dem was sich damit
verbindet und was ist dazwischen ein
ebenfalls starkes europa das aber in
diesem kontext er schwierigkeiten
bekommt als chancen
und insofern denke ich müssen wir jetzt
daran arbeiten dass zwischen den beiden
polen amerika asien ein erstarktes
europa sich entwickelt und das geht nur
wenn frankreich und deutschland zusammen
die führung übernehmen und in der nicht
nur in der geldpolitik durch die ezb
einig werden und ein einheitliches
konzept machen sondern auch in der
finanz- in der wirtschaftspolitik
und auch in der sozialpolitik denn die
differenzen dsd hat immer noch gibt
stärken uns ja nicht die schwächen uns
und deswegen setzen wir sehr bewusst
darauf macht europa einige damit es eine
rolle ökonomisch wie politisch in der
welt spielen kann die in diesem europa
zukommt in ihrem buch ist allerdings auf
spürbar dass jedoch eine gewisse skepsis
gegenüber den usa haben sagt ich jetzt
mal so
sie sagen auch die waren nie so nahe ich
bin eben nicht mit dem goldenen löffel
im mund geboren worden wie haben sie das
gemeint einmal das weil ich habe amerika
die abgelehnt hatte kein grund ich war
nie an die amerikanisch ich gehörte
nicht zu der generation der sogenannten
sechziger die die vielleicht aus anderen
gründen ich war gegen
krieg in vietnam ich war war auf der
straße in nördlingen um zu protestieren
zugunsten von kennedy während seiner
ermordung und habe gesagt dies ist ein
punkt um solidarität zu zeigen mit dem
anderen amerika das sich geschätzt habe
all das habe ich gemacht ich habe keine
anti amerikanische gefühle aber ich will
auch nicht dass wir in der
energiepolitik dass wir in anderen
fragen gleichsam der 51 staat der
vereinigten staaten von amerika sind
oder so behandelt werden nein wir sind
souveräner partner wollen das auch
bleiben aber das bedeutet und wir haben
das als bundesregierung etwa im rahmen
des irak-krieges gewissen wir
entscheiden selber was passiert
energiepolitisch außen und
sicherheitspolitisch und wir sind
niemanden anhänger sondern wir sind ein
souveräner staat und wollen das auch
bleiben
bleiben wir direkt bei der
energiepolitik und hierzu nordring zwei
eine gaspipeline die russland auf
direktem weg über die ostsee mit
deutschland verbinden soll
sagen wir direkt dazu sie sind tätig für
gazprom heißt also sie arbeiten für
diesen russischen staatskonzern und
haben natürlich vermutlich bei sie ein
interesse zu befürworten
die amerikaner sind dagegen haben ihre
eigenen gründe isoliert sich deutschland
nicht mit diesem projekt nein glaube ich
nicht zum beispiel es gibt ja bereits
nord stream 1 das 55 milliarden
kubikmeter gas aus russland nach
neckermann transferiert und
transportiert und wir brauchen die
zweite linie
warum wir sind aus der kernenergie
ausgestiegen in meiner zeit im übrigen
halte ich nach wie vor für richtig
wir müssen und wollen aus der kohle aus
klima gründen heraus und wir sollen
setzen auf erneuerbare energien
klar aber es wird nicht reichen den
absehbarer zeit um unsere wirtschaft mit
bezahlbarer energie zu versorgen also
brauchen wir für eine übergangszeit ob
sie nun 10 20 oder 30 jahre dauert kann
keiner wirklich beurteilen als einzig
vernünftigen umweltfreundlichen
fossilen energieträger gas und da müssen
wir fragen wo kriegen was her
so kann man ja nicht backen und die
deutschen lagerstätten sind erschöpft
die norwegischen sind an der grenze von
den holländischen will ich gar nicht
mehr reden so also brauchen wir
pipelinegas aus russland
wenn sie also flüchtet verflüssigtes gas
kriegen aus katar waren die amerikaner
uns auch liefern
im übrigen so leise grünen das kommt aus
fracking technologie die wir in
deutschland wenn es nach den grünen geht
nicht benutzen dürfen
aber in amerika scheint das dann in
ordnung zu sein wenn ist teurer
qualitativ schlechter und warum sollen
wir das machen wir sind nicht abhängig
von jemanden wir wissen seit
generationen das auch zu zeiten der
sowjetunion ordentlich geliefert wurde
wir haben ordentlich bezahlt werden nie
probleme damit warum soll das in zukunft
so sein
mir scheint da sehr viel ideologie im
schwange zu sein und weniger rationale
wirtschaftspolitik rationale
energiepolitik
es sollte nicht sein wir würden uns
damit allerdings natürlich wenn sie
sagen wir machen uns nicht abhängig von
jemandem bezug auf die amerikaner machen
wir uns selbstverständlich natürlich
aber doch abhängig von russland damit
und der vollständigkeit halber es gibt
auch zu denen die sagen wir brauchen
dieses gas nicht um sie habe ich schon
gehört ja weil ich meine aldi in diesen
studien verfassen sie müssen aufpassen
dass sie gegengehalten hinter kriegen im
winter denn ich meine wir sind aus der
kernenergie raus wollen dabei auch
bleiben ich bin dafür
wir müssen raus aus der kohle osten
klima gründen in einem längeren zeitraum
ich bin dafür und ich bin sehr dafür
dass wir auch wenn jubel setzen also
erneuerbare energieträger aber es wird
nicht reichen um ein industrieland wie
deutschland im funk funktionsfähig zu
halten also brauchen wir für die
nächsten 10 15 20 jahre gas als
brückentechnologie dafür arbeite ich
sehe nicht fasten zu kritisieren werden
wir müssen daher kriegen wo was ist wir
können es doch nicht
ich gehe davon aus dass es nicht
ehrenamtlich zu der studie
es ist ja wird überall veröffentlicht
was ich mache und da ist nix dran
abzusteigen natürlich ich bin jemand der
wirtschaftlich tätig ist und werde für
die tätigkeit zum beispiel als
rechtsanwalt auch bezahlt grund für die
ablehnung von nord sind zwei die sich
jetzt auch im europa-parlament breiter
macht auf die franzosen am signalisiert
dass sie nicht mehr unbedingt so freunde
sind von dieser idee mit der pipeline
ist unter anderem die verquickung mit
dem fall alexej nawalny ganz kurz
alexander wahlen wurde mit nori zog
vergiftet dem russischen kampfstoff hat
sich in deutschland erholt kehrte zurück
nach moskau um es noch mal kurz zu
rekapitulieren und ist diese woche in
einem kaum nachvollziehbaren urteil zu
einer mehrjährigen haftstrafe verurteilt
worden
es wurde eine bewährungsstrafe
umgewandelt in eine mehrjährige
haftstrafe
zurück dieses urteil hat international
große empörung ausgelöst wie sehen sie
das
also zunächst einmal äußere ich mich
nicht zu urteilen die ich nicht kenne
und das zweite was ich sagen will ist
folgendes warum verquickt man etwas
miteinander was nicht zusammengehört was
hat eine pipeline nord stream mit dem
fall von herne wanne zu tun
ich sehe das nicht und ich denke es ist
falsch beides miteinander zu verknüpfen
wenn man glaubte man würde daraus
dadurch druck auf russland ausüben um
irgendeine andere situation zu schaffen
dann irrt man und insofern verstehe ich
all diejenigen nicht die meinen wenn man
jetzt neuesten streich oder zu ende
bringt oder nicht zu ende bringt also
stoppt dann würde sich bezogen auf den
fall den sie erwähnt haben irgendwas
ändern
das sehe ich nicht so und deswegen
glaube ich man muss das
auseinanderhalten das eine hat mit dem
anderen nichts zu tun und ich gehöre
nicht zu denen die meinen der reden ja
auch über das buch das wir geschrieben
dass kein buch über neuwahlen die sonne
ein
auch über die rolle russland in der
internationalen politik und unser
interesse auch perspektivisch russland
als partner zu erhalten
wir haben 1 doch historisch begriffen
alle miteinander immer dann wenn es
schlecht war im verhältnis zwischen
deutschland und russland ging schief was
frieden in der welt angeht immer dann
wenn es erträglich war was besser und
deswegen unabhängig von innenpolitischen
problemen die andere kommentieren mögen
unabhängig davon geht es doch darum für
die eu wenn sie eine rolle spielen will
zwischen denen die ich erwähnt habe
amerika auf der einen seite jene auf der
anderen seite darum partner zu haben
eine sehr wichtig ist bleibt russland
egal was in politik passiert und bleibt
zum anderen die türkei auch egal was in
politisch passiert was mir auch nicht
immer gefällt gehen wir noch mal zu dem
preis der erträglichkeit zurück an
dieser stelle und lösen wird in fahrt
zum 2 von dem fall navalny da möchte ich
doch gern noch mal mit ihnen gemeinsam
hingucken
die bundeskanzlerin hat die sofortige
freilassung der wahl nichts gefordert
viele namenhafte andere politiker sich
angeschlossen
denn damit schon sie schauen sie ich
gehöre nicht zu denjenigen die das
nachwirken was andere für richtig warum
sollte ich das das tue ich nicht
und insofern kann ich nachvollziehen die
position der bundeskanzlerin aber jetzt
nicht meine
nun ist es ja so dass der fahrer waren
die auch in russland doch erhebliche
demonstrationen auslöst
[Musik]
wir haben auch miteinander vereinbart
dass wir über ein buch werden aber wir
wollen ich habe das steht in dem buch
spielt nichts miteinander wollen aber
wir reden natürlich auch über tag und
sie als jemand der russland versteht ja
könnt ihr uns hier ist das eigentlich
was schlimmes oder anders nutzen wir in
diesem derby
wir sind das interessante ist so
diejenigen die als russland versteher
gelten
die werden ja in deutschland in den
medien natürlich nicht bei ihnen so ein
bisschen abschätzig behandelt wenn nicht
sogar diskriminiert aber was soll
eigentlich politik sein wenn man nicht
in der lage ist die jeweils andere seite
zu verstehen kann man noch keine
rationale politik machen man muss ja
nicht billigen was da passiert tue ich
auch in vielen fragen nicht aber
wenigstens den versuch zu machen zu
kapieren was sind denn die gründe auf
der anderen seite das sollte man schon
machen und im übrigen noch einmal das
buch handelt von internationaler politik
und nicht von herrn derweil gut dann
gehen wir jetzt so ein putin dafür von
ihm handelt nämlich das buch durchaus
und der staat sprich denn je und zwar in
freien wählen wollen gewählter starts
waren übrigens neben hals gab es hier
große größere kritik an der tatsache
dass er wirklich in freien wahlen
gewählt worden
was spricht dagegen mit ihnen befreundet
und kennen ihn viele jahre gut es gab ja
eine fast schon einige zeit während
ihrer kanzlerschaft nach dem immerhin
hatte eine rede im deutschen bundestag
viel beachtete wenn sie sich an putin
heute anschauen und auf die letzten
jahre zurückschauen was würden sie sagen
hatte sich verändert und wenn in welcher
es wäre doch wäre doch komisch wenn sich
menschen im laufe eines langen lebens
nicht veränderten
die waren ja ob sie die geschichte von
herrn k von bertolt brecht kennen
rks herr kauder und herr k trifft ein
freund und der sache zu herrn k sie
haben sich über gar nicht verändert herr
kaiser und er bleibt natürlich verändert
sich ein mensch im laufe des lebens ich
auch sie auch und ich hoffe zum
positiven
also was soll die frage natürlich hat
sich auch herr putin verändert im laufe
seines lebens und durch den job auf
jeden fall nur das was ich als
freundschaft bezeichnet
begonnen in einer zusammenarbeit die
produktiv war für beide seiten für
deutschland wie für russland und daraus
hat sich eine menschliche beziehung
entwickelt und eine menschliche
beziehung wenn sie so wollen eine
freundschaft da muss man doch nicht
immer einer meinung sein
freundschaft besteht doch auch darin
dass man unterschiedliche positionen
austragen kann dies durchaus gibt die
man aber wenn der andere noch staatschef
eines der wichtigsten länder der welt
ist nicht öffentlich austrägt sondern
wenn man unterschiede in der bewertung
hat die es gibt dann tut mir das noch
nicht im deutschen fernsehen gut sein
wie bei veränderten beziehung damit
haben sie mich das stichwort geliefert
wir haben mal dass ihre partei das
bleibt meine würde ja weil man also mit
allen möglichen leuten
parteivorsitzenden tobago wir abgekürzt
wird norbert walter borjans und saskia
esken haben gesagt mit der agenda 2010
sei die spd damals von ihrem kurs
abgekommen wie beurteilen sie gar nicht
diese aussage weil dieser dieser kurs
ist auf parteitag mit drei viertel
mehrheiten beschlossen worden
mehr kann man eigentlich nicht erreichen
auf seinem parteitag und war keine
geschichte die ich etwa der partei
oktroyiert hätte ich halte sie nach wie
vor für vernünftig und ich muss das mal
sehr deutlich sagen wenn sich meine
situation in europa anschauen
die wichtigsten partner von uns ob das
urteil den ist frankreich ist portugal
ist spanien ist wenn immer sie in den
dritten satz nun mal da raus weil sie
draußen sind inzwischen so wie geht es
den denn die haben die reform die unter
meiner führung seiner zeit eingeleitet
worden sind nicht oder zu spät gemacht
bisher etliche bisher nicht und ließ den
wirtschaftlich besser und den menschen
die an arbeit denken und ihre familien
ernähren wollen jetzt den besser als den
menschen in deutschland nein es geht
ihnen schlechter und deswegen finde ich
eine parteiführung die nicht begreift
dass das was wir mit der agenda gemacht
haben deutschland stärker und ich
schwächer gemacht haben übrigens auch
die wähler der spd eher besser hat
dastehen lassen als das gegenteil das
verstehe ich nicht und das ist mein
konflikt denn ich habe mit der
parteiführung den wir diskutieren
gelegentlich ich rappe nova oder so
sollten genauso gut genauso getroffen
wie auch den kühen hat frau es können
kenne ich nicht aber schön und rede mit
denen sage ihnen meine meinung aber eben
auch nicht öffentlich und gut ich habe
eine andere vorstellung meine endet er
derjenigen wenn ich überhaupt jemand
nennen sollte sind interessanterweise
zwei frauen wo ich glaube dass sie den
tollen job machen eine ist die
ministerpräsidentin von mitteln vor
bevor schließlich und dass man in sachen
gas zusammen
das ist schon deren eigene position hat
mit mehr relativ wenig zu tun ein
die anderes frank ev die in berlin daran
trägt und sagt wir kommen zurück nach
berlin da kommt sie her und will dass
dieser stadt wieder besser geht und das
sind zwei frauen die sagen okay wenn wir
etwas besser machen wollen dann müssen
wir auch wirtschaftspolitische kompetenz
ausstrahlt beide sagen dass beide tun
dass und interessanterweise weiter haben
deswegen erfolg was mich freut möbel und
andere die meinen man könnte ein land
wie deutschland regieren ohne
ökonomische kompetenz die irren
auch wenn die sozialdemokraten sind im
hinblick auf die bundestagswahl in
diesem jahr haben sie des öfteren
prognostiziert dass es mit einem schwarz
grünen regierungsbündnis enden wird auch
das
nehmen teil ihrer partei ein bisschen
übel weil sie sagen sie glauben nicht an
die kraft der sozialdemokratie aber
warum nehmen - über chance ich lese um
fragen wie jeder von ihnen auch und wir
sind nun mal so wie sie sind wenn ich
von heute an sagen soll was ist
wahrscheinlich dann wäre das doch
verlogen wenn ich sagte ja spd dich
davor ist sie gegenwärtig nicht muss
viel passieren wenn sie auch nur
annähernd in die situation kommen will
den kanzler zu stellen sie hat eine
wichtige entscheidung getroffen nämlich
olaf scholz zu nominieren
das schon mal 5 aber natürlich geht es
jetzt um die frage wer schreibt
eigentlich welches wahlprogramm so
schreibt olaf olaf scholz ein
wahlprogramm das ihm entspricht mit dem
er arbeiten kann ohne unglaubwürdig zu
werden oder fischen eben da irgendwelche
leute rein wenn er selber in der lage
ist seine position
die sehr rational sind durchzusetzen und
die im wahlprogramm sich auch
wiederfinden wenn ich gerne bereit die
dinge anders zu beurteilen aber das muss
man sehen und im übrigen was soll das
wenn man diese umfragen gegenwärtig
sieht und als jemand der ein politischer
mensch ist eine einschätzung geben soll
soll ich da lügen oder was würden sie
glauben wenn die spd gegenwärtig in
diesen zeiten bedauerlicherweise
schwächer ist als die grünen in den
umfragen
das wird nicht so bleiben davon bin ich
überzeugt aber gegenwärtig ist das so
soll ich dann so tun als wenn das nicht
stimmte und war als wenn das nicht zu
berücksichtigen wäre das würde doch
keine kein mensch ernst nehmen und den
grenzen billigsten ernst genommen werden
da hat mir auch keiner überleben
abschließend die frage herr schröder sie
tragen seit vielen jahren den spitznamen
ak-wahl wieso unermüdlich acker kämpfen
kann ja auch mal gefahren in sich bergen
wenn sie auf die letzten jahrzehnte
zurück schauen haben sie das gefühl sie
haben sich
irgendeiner stelle vielleicht auch mal
verkämpft verkämpft nicht immer gekämpft
zunächst zum sozialen aufstieg den ich
über bildung versucht habe und
ausbildung zu leisten übrigens eine
geschichte die mich immer umgetrieben
hat und ich finde wir müssen weiter
dafür kämpfen dass menschen mit dem
sozialen hintergrund wie mein eigener
über bildung aufsteigen können in der
gesellschaft und wenn sie was tun wenn
sie eine chance erhalten und dafür will
ich weiter kämpfen
alles was ich gemacht habe hat sich bei
allen fehlern die jeder macht natürlich
letztlich so gefügt dass ich von mir
selber sagen kann na ja das hätte
schlechter laufen können in meinem leben
eigentlich und gerade jetzt wieder bin
ich ein glücklicher mensch
gerhard schröder herzlichen dank für das
gespräch
gerne
[Musik]